When it comes to dealing with the environment, what is the
biggest risk that you can be exposed to if you're not very
well prepared for it? Because being prepared for
something like that is only experience, and experience comes
from trying and getting to know about things.
So there's no ideal way to go out and saying that, yes, this
is how I will do it unless you've actually done it a few
times. And then they're like, no, OK, I
need to fine tune it a bit. So I totally agree with you and
many people would say, I would say this because it's my
passion, but I would say don't underestimate these
environmental factors. I think we have a tendency to do
that. If we think about the
environmental factors that can affect us, they're really oxygen
level, cold G force and sun exposure.
I would say like those are the main ones.
The oxygen thing is interesting because I've flown a lot in
India. It's my favorite place to fly.
I was fortunate to fly in Pakistan a few years ago and
that was wonderful as well. And to go up nice and high.
Undoubtedly low levels of oxygen affect us.
They affect our ability to think.
They affect in some cases, if it gets low enough, our ability to
see effectively in terms of our peripheral vision.
All of those things narrow. They affect our ability to
control the glider. And they also have a bit of a
hangover effect. So if you get hypoxic and then
you go down to a lower altitude, you feel better, but you're
still not back to 100% for probably up to about 90 minutes.
For those wondering what's hypoxic?
So hypoxia is low levels of oxygen in the blood.
Technically the term for that is hypoxemia, but I would think
about it as we're in an environment when we fly high
where the pressure is low. That means that the oxygen
molecules, there's still 20% oxygen, same as there is at sea
level, but they're all further apart.
So that means to get the same amount in, you have to breathe
faster, which is why actually flying at house 2 is so
dehydrating, because what's happening is you're breathing in
and out lots and you're shedding water each time you do so that
that's one of the reasons why it's dehydrating.
The other reason is because the oxygen levels are lower.
Your kidneys don't work as well, so you don't conserve water in
the same way, which is why you desperately need to pee when you
fly at high altitude or in cold environments.
So oxygen's definitely a thing. It's hard to know what height it
starts to matter at because that depends quite a lot on different
people and it also depends on and by different people.
Climatisation, sorry, genetics and fitness, it also depends on
a climatisation. We'll talk about that in a SEC.
The there's a very easy way to fix it, which is to carry
supplementary oxygen, But there's also a lot of associated
faff that comes with carrying supplementary oxygen.
But I can only say from personal experience that when I flew with
it in Pakistan, when I switched it on, suddenly my mood
improved. I felt warmer.
I could think more clearly. I almost felt like I could.
I don't know if I could physically see better.
I just felt less blinkered. But I felt a striking increase
in bandwidth. So it's changed my perception a
little bit in terms of I knew academically that hypoxia was an
issue. It's first, it takes a while to
really feel it, and when you feel it, you're like OK.
Or when you feel it going away or improving with oxygen, it
strikes you how much it might be affecting you.
What are the first symptoms that come to you that you can
understand? Because as we spoke about in the
beginning of the show, that it's such a cognitively heavy load
and there's so much to look and observe and be constantly
thinking that it's so easy to be drifted away.
So how do you identify that this might be coming in the next
10-15 minutes? This is why your point about
experience is such a good one, because everybody has their own.
It's called a hypoxic signature. And so if you're a fighter
pilot, you get put in a chamber, you get made hypoxic and then
you get a load of puzzles and other things to do.
And there's some brilliant videos of all these like
incredibly macho U.S. Marine pilots, just like mashing
like kids toys together. It's fun to watch.
But the purpose of that training for them is both to realise that
they don't know they're impaired, but also to try and
work out exactly what you said, like how did they feel in the
the time leading up to that impairment?
Because it varies. And so finding our own hypoxic
signature as paraglider pilots is a little bit difficult
because we don't have access to these chambers.
But I think one of the way to do it is to really try and be
observant of yourself when you go into these environments.
So if say I'm in beer, I'm going over the back, I'm flying up
above 4000 metres asking myself what am I feeling, what can I
see, what can I think? And actually, because I was
quite interested in this, I put a little note on my cockpit to
remind me to think about what I'm thinking because you can get
so in the zone. But typically for people, they
would say things like mood changes.
So you either feel pretty euphoric or you feel a bit sad
or a bit constrained or a bit afraid.
Not having as big a bandwidth, some changes in motor skills, so
you're not thermalling as nicely as you would normally.
You're bouncing in and out. Then as you get more hypoxic,
the way you communicate with others might be a thing.
So sometimes people become less commutative, sometimes they
become quite garrulous, sometimes they start talking a
bit of nonsense. Certainly if that's happening,
it's too late. But that's also the advantage of
flying with buddies because they can point out to you that this
thing is happening. Obviously, the most kind of
telling sign that it might be happening is just the fact that
you are high. So taking a note of your
altitude and think that OK, that I'm now entering A vulnerable
place. And I would say probably about
for most people because this varies a lot between
individuals. Once you start flying above 3000
meters, certainly 3 1/2, you are going to be subject to this all
right. Let's say how many minutes above
3000? Because a lot of times we are, I
wouldn't say exactly dolphining. You're getting high, lower,
high, lower, like depending on the glides.
So when do you start hitting the point of no return that OK, now
I'm pushing my limits and then hypoxia is a very real thing now
because I've been doing this for like past two hours.
So again, there's no evidence specific to paragliders, but
that I guess the aviation like general aviation would be above
10,000 feet for 30 minutes or above 13,000 feet for any period
of time. So I don't know what 10,000 feet
is that about 2802 thousand 600 metres, something like that.
But that's the general aviation guidance.
But it's so individual, like if you're, again, if you're tired,
hungover, dehydrated, your tolerance is going to be worse
if you're acclimatised. And a climate like whether
paragliding is acclimatising or not isn't really known.
But the thing that is most acclimatising is the altitude at
which you sleep. So if you sleep at high
altitude, you know, a little bit higher than normal or closer to
the altitude at which you fly, then that is going to help you
tolerate the hypoxia. The really interesting 1 though,
for me though is cold. Because when we think about
hypoxia, we're thinking about supply what's available in the
atmosphere, but also demand how much your body is using.
And it's that balance or that lack of balance that creates the
problems. And if you start shivering, your
oxygen consumption goes up by about five times, and oxygen is
being used to keep you warm. And if you can make sure that
you're stay nice and warm and you certainly don't shiver, then
I think that's one of the most helpful things you can do to
give yourself more margin when you're flying.
You're in a hypoxic environment.